wde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft heute spielen wir
ein spielmodus den ich zum ersten mal
oder spiele und zwar heißt der gute
spielmodus jump jump kann man das karte
zeigen nein hier ist unsichtbare wand
auf jeden fall hier außen steht dran den
modus kann man auf bergwerke labs
punkt.de spielen gehen ist in so einer
lobby kann die leute mit hallo es ist
noch unsicher ob man ist nach unten
abgesichert
die sozialisierung funktioniert ganz gut
man kann den leuten mit rechtlich
herausfordern oder man macht das was ich
jetzt gerade machen und zwar einen
schnell beitritt da hat mich ein
parcours und jump jump heißt wenn man es
jetzt auch deutsche besitzen würde promi
sprung und ja gut es geht uns springen
das dürfte eigentlich relativ klar sei
und ich spiele zum ersten mal sind im
modus vor halben stunde zum ersten mal
entdeckt quasi schon davor bei einem
video gesehen aber nicht wirklich
gespielt
sehr schön first try ohne fällen
eisdiele tropic von marc die an hier
auch ein ganzes teil aber hat ein paar
ganz tricky
wie nennt man es eigentlich ja fans
jumps also es geht um diese zaun stäbe
da wieso ich bin doch gerade eben nicht
machen die einmal gestorben in der map
davor hat mit trotzdem da unten ich bin
oder bei 2 923 hat mir trotzdem vor eben
fehler gezeigt obwohl ich nicht
gestorben wenn nachweislich nachweislich
nicht gestorben
das genau die stelle hätte ich meine da
muss man ja das risiko da muss man
nämlich ganz auslaufen
dadurch dass die fans das nochmal ich
glaube den halben blog höher
als sie angezeigt werden irgendwie so
man steht auf jeden fall immer guten der
luft aber für fans ist wenn ich gleich
auf einem steht kann ich euch das auch
noch mal zeigen aber erstmal drauf
kommen genauso jetzt guck mal hier lerne
ich dir also man steht irgendwie in der
luft das liegt daran ja ich glaube es
ist ein halber blog fans in hamburg
höher als nein
und man muss auch immer weiter springen
als sonst der angriff auf einer höhe
sieht wie rechts die anzeige geld
gesprochen hat was passiert wenn wir
gerade auf einer höhe waren immer so
einen blog vor dem anderen
jetzt hat er ja gut
also muss eben ein bisschen weiter
springen habe ich das gefühl
okay noch mal ja bitte bring ich jetzt
in sicherheit bringen sicherheit
dankeschön checkpoint es gibt
checkpoints leute das wusste ich nicht
war sie also jetzt hält ich spiele
spielt oder sie wirklich blind ist ganz
witzig ist dass wir so wie jump league
er musste auf den zaun springen und
leute auch ganz cool ganz coole anekdote
ich hab grad eben davor flash gespielt
und ich hab jetzt nicht den typischen
flash job mit normaler geschwindigkeit
koller die man sonst im h2 gambling oder
ist ob es einen trick
es geht eigentlich ganz gut es geht
endlich ganz gut muss ich sagen obwohl
ich jetzt gerade direkt aus fleisch
komme wollte eigentlich aufnehmen aber
dann gab es da nur gta und gta mag ich
nicht also die märkte nicht auf dem
server eigentlich auf bergwerk labs gibt
es in flash einem apps gta und dieser
versuch das hallo dies ultra schwer und
vor allem solange und wenn ich das
spielen würde wirklich dann dann habe
ich übrigens meinen pc kaputt so beim
letzten mal schon so beim letzten mal
flash habe ich mir schon gta meine ich
habe ich schon ordentlich randaliert und
die leute davon ist es ziel ist es so
nah und doch so fern stream noch mal
einfach mal 24 blog sprünge davon
nein ich kann das nicht wenn ich stehen
bleibe da kann ich dann keine viele
bürger machen stetig muss durch laufen
derweil da vor dem wenn ich noch so groß
zelebriert und sage jetzt geht es darum
dann klappt's erst recht nicht
aber wir kommen der eigentlich recht
schon hin hat der muss mehr auslaufen
da haben sie die durchlauf taktik ein
bisschen blockiert und verhindert indem
man da so wie sie nach rechts muss davon
nichts
und zwar hier muss man rechts runter
genau und jetzt sagt sagt sagt oder
kolonie böse live ist wahrscheinlich alt
ich bin drauf und rutscht unter kamera
ist nicht dein ernst es ist nicht ein
fucking ernst ich muss da durch face kam
ein bisschen raussuchen
aber egal haben heute eine close up
verlasst nein nein nicht das spiel
verlassen der garde ich wollte ich
endlich schaffen gerade eben aber
irgendwie wollte er nicht mal kurz die
fans kommen raus leute darf ich das ein
bisschen creepy aus das ist ganz ultra
na ja so ist besser alles da sieht man
auch dass ich jetzt nicht nur aus kopf
und neues gesicht bestehe dass auch
besieht scheinen ist heute die
temperatur geschuldet ich würde mich
schon auf die nächste okay die kennen
sich auch nicht nochmals martin hier
wobei die bekommt irgendwoher kommt mir
bekannt vor
irgendwoher kommt mir diese map bekannt
voraus irgendeinem jump'n'run spiel
welches könnte das sein
irgendwoher kenne ich die früher habe
ich schon mal gespielt vor langer langer
zeit
ok oh ja das ist so krass allerdings
richtig schwierig alter schwede deg muss
weg bin ein rückkehrer spielt man das
irgendwie abgedreht die leute verlassen
die ganze nation eine pariser
musikpreise es liegt nicht daran dass
diese mehr hab einfach so richtig
geisteskrank ist nein ich muss ich muss
weg ich habe gerade jetzt eine gleichen
bewerbungsgespräch vorstellungsgespräch
an einem dienstag um 18 uhr abends muss
er glaub ich hab eben weg ich will
einfach mal sagen leute was haltet ihr
von dem spielmodus las sie am besten in
den kommentaren wissen vielleicht gucken
wir ob jetzt noch mal ne kurze weg
finden wenn sie mal eine kurze map
kriegen dann könne das war ein mäppchen
haben wir hier noch mädchen so sehr wie
das was man früher in der schule mit
sich herumtrug ja wo die stifterin waren
wachsen so sehr gehasst ruhig beginnen
rascher girl altern eis direkt aus
moskau mit dem 500er pinken die kann
froh sind das finde ich jetzt geh spiel
soll ich die derbe rasieren oder ok nice
an diesem einen sprung hängt sei um
gerade egal wie packen als kam zack zack
zack ist ganz nett thema hat ihr so
diese sicherung ja so ziemlich gut
so machen wir das noch mal
das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
schwierig ist ein bisschen dinges und
jetzt hier noch mal in vier workshops
zum abstieg berlin 29 23 hat das spiel
gewonnen jetzt nie